alert
breaking this afternoon president biden
lays out some aggressive next steps to
combat the coronavirus pandemic he says
our country is in a tough stretch right
now thanks so much for joining us at 4
i'm kirsten joyce and i'm christian
casarez while the delta variant
continues to surge infections around the
country this week the u.s hit 650
thousand covet related deaths skyler
henry has the president's remarks from
the white house
president biden's plan for tackling the
cobit pandemic is a six-step approach
focusing on public health schools and
the economy we have the tools to combat
cover 19
and a distinct minority of americans
supported by a stink minority of elected
officials are keeping us from turning
the corner the president signed an
executive order requiring federal
executive branch workers be vaccinated
another extends the same standard to
employees of contractors that do
business with the federal government if
a federal worker fails to comply they
will go through the standard hr process
which includes counseling
and face disciplinary action the white
house says the labor department is
developing a rule that businesses with
more than 100 employees require
vaccination or weekly testing the
administration is also calling on states
to adopt vaccination requirements for
employees that work at schools
we're going to protect vaccinated
workers from unvaccinated co-workers